[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ce soir vous le savez mesdames et
messieurs c'est une spéciale the cover
les stars se sont mobilisés pour venir
faire des reprises en plateau et
moi-même je dois le dire j'ai décidé de
chanter tout à fait une très belle
soirée sans promo sans rien a gagné et
en l'honneur de laquelle j'ai décidé de
vous interpréter une reprise de savoir
aimer de Florent P mais savoir donner
donner sans reprendre ne rien faire
qu'apprendre apprendre ou à laisser
apprendre ou à laisser mon nouveau
jeu mon nouveau jeu du lundi au vendredi
à 17h avec tous les jours 100000 € à la
clé sans oublier tous les jours le
maillon faible é PMP les vendredis et
parfois le mercredi vous l'avez compris
mon but c'est de faire le plus d'heur
possible à l'antenne plus d'heur que
cyil Hanouna c'est dur mais je
m'accroche et puis suite à l'arrêt de la
carrière internationale de Franck
riberry il y a un couple qui voulait
chanter en duo une chanson de Serge
ginzebourg c'est justement Franck
riberri etd des
chants
bonjour tu vas tu vas et tu
viens en équipe de France et je te
retiens je ve je v et je
viens dans l'équipe de France mais je me
[Musique]
retiens
là allez nous allons
maintenant nous allons maintenant
accueillir un grand admirateur de la
chanson française à texte j'ai nommé le
grand Stéphane merde mon cher
Julien vous le savez j'aime la grande la
belle chanson française j'ai un faible
particulier d'ailleurs pour cette grande
dame qui est Barbara et que je vais
modestement tenter de
reprendre un beau jour ou peut-être une
nuit près d'un black mtais endormi oh
non j'ai mal articulé ce qui me fait
d'ailleurs penser à un autre air très
connu si tu avances et tu recules
comment veux-tu comment veux-tu que
j'articule non on a le droit à chaque
fois ça
allez ce soir il y a même un ministre
qui nous fait l'honneur de venir chanter
pour nous puisque Arnaud montebour a
décidé de faire une reprise
salut salut toi écoutez monsieur Courbet
comme j'ai quitté le gouvernement j'ai
effectivement fait une reprise pour
François Hollande pour Manuel Vals et
tous les sauces du terterre de l'Élysée
c'est il part pour la section d'assaut
aviation 3 4 j'ai préféré partir
isolé comment te dire je suis désolé et
j'ai côtoyé le
par je me suis dit désolé François Manu
désolé voilà
salut bonne
nouvelle pour fêter the cover de coun on
a aussi une chanson interprétée par
Denis Brognard bonjour à tous j'ai aussi
une reprise qui pourrait bientôt devenir
l'hyne officiel de
colant c'est parti et soudain surgifa
sauvant le vrai héros de tous les temps
Bob mundir contre tout chacal aventurier
contre tout
[Rires]
guerrierel aventurier solitaire Bob
mundir est le roi de la
[Applaudissements]
terre la chanson c'est aussi bien sû des
duos inoubliables et on termine avec un
duo qui risque effectivement d'être
difficile à oublier puisque c'est Nelson
manfort et Philippe Cando qui SLE
écoutez tout à fait mon cher Julien avec
Philippe cand nous avons décidé de faire
une reprise d'un petit groupe punk assz
pe connu les Pun du Daft ou com on les
appelle en anglais les DA
Pun je me
lance
à vous mon cher Philippe cand on est
debout toute la nuit on reste debout
toute la nuit nous t ce qu'on veut c'est
nous t ce qu'on veut c'est
déglinguer tout le monde nous t ce qu'on
veut c'est nous t ce qu'on veut
c'est allez Jean-Michel à
toi c'était Marc Antoine le
[Musique]
merciation
y